in the world of Joker
today's theory will show that the
biggest joke of all is on us
hello Internet
welcome to film theory where we just
encourage you to smile just smiling now
I gotta be honest when I first saw an
announcement about a Joker solo movie
shortly after the release of Suicide
Squad I thought it was all one bad joke
I mean let's just say that most people
weren't super thrilled with that movie's
characterization of such an iconic
villain this handsome so coming back for
yet another version of the character so
soon was surprised to say the least
then the trailer came out and I was
stunned this wasn't gonna be a film
about billionaire superheroes with bat
nipples beating up thugs and rainbow
colored streets instead it was gonna be
a dive into the psychology of a man man
named Arthur Fleck a man plagued by
mental illness a man forgotten by
government and abused by society a man
just like any other completely
unremarkable except for one small detail
we're told by the title of the movie
that he's gonna rise to take the title
of comics greatest super villain the
Joker it's the sort of deconstruction of
the genre that I love and I think we're
all desperate for don't get me wrong I
love the spectacle of superhero movies
but after more than a decade of flashy
CGI battles with big villains and even
bigger budgets look it's me most excited
are the ones brave enough to show us
something darker stuff like Logan or the
boys story set in universes of
superheroes but where good and evil
aren't so clear-cut
where the heroes aren't always the good
guys films that don't just gloss over
the rotten underbelly of the society
that needs heroes to rescue it in the
first place and Joker seems to take all
those boxes but there was something else
that I found interesting about Joker
when watching the trailers
I think it's real now obviously the
movie exists that's not what I'm saying
here know what I mean to say is that
anytime you have a film telling such a
close personal story of a character
who's clearly struggling with mental
illness it leaves open the possibility
for misdirection for the film to
suddenly descend into hallucinations for
the camera itself to be an unreliable
narrator as it depicts not reality as
it's truly happening but rather reality
as its characters were in this case
Arthur Fleck wants to see it for an
example of what I mean just look at
Fight Club the ultimate example of a
movie that's lying to you the entire
time and the more I looked into the
trailers interviews around this film and
the source material that inspired at the
more convinced I became what we're going
to end up seeing in Joker isn't going to
be entirely real the movie or at least a
sizable portion of it is gonna be
playing out in Joker's own mind what
we're gonna end up seeing on screen may
not be what's actually happening in
Gotham around the setting of the movie
but how and why let's look a bit closer
shall we let's start by dissecting
Arthur himself
the trailers introduce us to Arthur
Fleck which it's worth noting is a new
name for Joker's character no official
name has ever been given to the Joker in
the main cannon DC Comics and Jack
Napier from the Tim Burton movies and
the alternate universe white knight is
about as close as we've ever come before
in fact the team working on Joker made
it pretty explicit that this story is
entirely original so no digging through
deep comic lore is gonna be helping us
out this time around it's immediately
communicated to us from the trailers
that Arthur is suffering from some form
of mental illness not only do we see him
in therapy but if you look close at his
notepad it outright confirms it reading
quote the worst part about having a
mental illness is people expect you to
behave as if you don't this is also
confirmed by numerous interviews done
with the casting crew the film according
to actor Marc Maron in an interview with
website NME quote the approach that todd
phillips has taken is more of an origin
story and a character study of a
mentally ill person that becomes the
joker unquote so we know that Arthur
Fleck is dealing with some mental
disorder but what sort of illness is it
clearly not all mental illnesses
function the same way so to better
understand
this character and thus the movie he's a
part of we have to first understand his
diagnosis looking at the trailers we see
a few curious details that could be
symptoms of Arthur's illness first he
appears to have inappropriate emotional
responses laughing without any sort of
stimulus laughing after being beat up
switching into an out of laughter
instantly and well out of nowhere
uncontrollable laughter is indeed a real
medical condition known as pseudobulbar
affect there are more symptoms here that
don't line up with that initial
diagnosis symptoms such as moments of
violent outbursts or inappropriate
actions smashing himself against
protective screens smashing himself
against mirrors painting his own tongue
generally speaking Arthur's movements
feel awkward watching him walk and dance
in both trailers feels uncomfortable
feels disjointed he's jerky his feet are
moving in strange patterns the illness
also seems to be hereditary with his
mother needing at-home care despite
appearing rather young and in what
otherwise would seem to be good health
all of these symptoms seem to point to
Joker's vague mental illness being more
precisely diagnosed as schizophrenia a
chronic mental disorder characterized by
a breakdown between what someone
perceives as reality and what's really
happening around them look at this list
of characteristics and think back to
what we just talked about with regards
to Arthur inexact motor skills jerking
our movements awkward gait unusual
gestures or postures feelings of
detachment sudden anger social isolation
it's almost an exact match for the
behavior that we see Arthur exhibiting
throughout these two trailers and
schizophrenia does indeed have a strong
genetic component even the handwriting
on his joke pad is a clue to his real
diagnosis here notice how the writing
gets more and more disorganized as it
goes on well compare that to what we see
in this study from the paper differences
in handwriting's of schizophrenia
patients and you can clearly see the
exact same style of traits the size and
pressure of the pen marks differ it's
messy and outside the bounds of the
lines the letters are poorly formed
without treatment people with
schizophrenia tend to have problems in
society because of a feeling that
they've lost touch with reality in large
part due to schizophrenias key symptom
delusions and hallucinations and it's
those two symptoms that seem really
pertinent to our theory today about what
is and isn't real in this new Joker
movie you see in the lead up to the
premiere of Joker you keep seeing one
other movie constantly being mentioned
1982's the king of comedy a film
directed by Martin Scorsese now for his
famous of a director as Martin Scorsese
is delivering iconic movies like
Goodfellas taxi driver the departed and
Raging Bull King of Comedy it's not to
be one of his better known works and yet
here it is being cited as a key point of
inspiration for what we'll end up seeing
in Joker quote there's a connection
obviously with the whole thing but it's
not as a direct connection this is
according to actor Robert De Niro who
plays the main character struggling
stand-up comic and king of comedy and
once you know it is also a major
stand-up comic TV show host that we see
in Joker but outside of sharing this one
actor in somewhat similar roles in a
setting of a New York style city in a
crime filled 1980s the connections
between the two films seem to go deeper
much deeper and King of Comedy we have
ourselves Rupert Pupkin a socially
awkward and mentally ill comedian who
idolizes a stand-up TV host eventually
turning violent as he kidnaps and holds
the TV host hostage just so he can get
his 15 minutes of fame on the show it's
not grammatically correct but I think
you have the idea he does this at least
in part to impress a young woman named
Rita that he finds himself in love with
and what do we see in the Joker trailers
well we have ourselves a socially
awkward mentally ill comedian who
becomes a villain that we know is prone
to violence a villain who somehow
manages to wind up on the TV talk show
of a famous TV comic a man who based on
the trailers is trying to use his car
to impress a young woman that he happens
to have romantic feelings for so we have
ourselves a lot of key plot elements
shared between the two movies but even
some scenes feel like they're direct
parallels both characters live with
their mothers both characters have exact
wishes for how they'd like to be
introduced now this is my introduction
and I'd like mr. Randall if he could
speak it word for word I would
appreciate that this is Randy's
introduction to your monologue is one
small thing yeah when you bring me out
can you introduce me as Joker even shots
like this of the Joker getting ready to
walk out on stage is similar to a motif
of shots used throughout King of Comedy
somewhere in the middle of the city
thank you I appreciate it
tomorrow you'll know that I wasn't
kidding and you'll think I was crazy but
look I figure it this way better to be
king for a night then schmuck for a
lifetime so why do all these parallels
matter well throughout King of Comedy
mixed in with the real-life events of
Rupert kidnapping his TV Idol or
Rupert's fantasies his delusions are
blended seamlessly with the scenes that
are happening around them there's no
visual cue that were suddenly in the
middle of one of Roberts fantasies no
special filters no dream sequence fade
nothing the only way that you can tell
that these are Rupert's delusions is
because of the subject matter
Rupert is best friends with the TV host
he gets married to Rita he charms the
audience on the show and this technique
of mixing the fantasy and the reality
throws the entire ending of the movie
into question we're told that Rupert
gets out of jail and becomes a wildly
successful because of all the press that
his kidnapping scheme generated but
again this is a movie where
hallucination and reality blur is this
all in his mind as he sits there in his
prison cell it could be but it could
also not be the ending leaves it
ambiguous
Rupert Pupkin lady
let's hear it for Rupert Pupkin
at the same time it raises questions
about Joker and what we've seen in the
trailers certainly the dark scenes of
Arthur being beat up seem to jive with
the reality of an 80s era Gotham but
what about the scenes in which massive
crowds all wear clown masks while
protesting the government at first
glance one might think that this is a
pretty typical scene in a Batman film
the main villain has enthralled the city
with some kind of political message
perhaps turning him against the bat but
this isn't a Batman film that little kid
right there that is her future Batman so
it seems highly unlikely that he's gonna
suit up to take down mr. J so that leads
to the question what's really happening
here has Gotham actually turned against
the Wayne's in this movie or is Arthur
fantasizing about some kind of grand
revenge where everyone in Gotham takes
up his image and fights the power we
have some hints that it might be that
latter option throughout the trailers
were treated to two very different
images of Arthur as a clown one makes
him look like the sign twirler he
appears to be at the beginning of the
trailer while the other makes him look
like the Joker as we traditionally know
him whenever he's in the more standard
suit Arthur's life seems to be grounded
in reality he lives in poverty he cares
for his mother he's barely making ends
meet he's struggling to become a
stand-up comic but whenever we see him
in his Joker suit suddenly everything
changes he's on stage he's walking
through crowds of people dressed like
him he's dancing around on stairs
everything he does in this Joker suit
seems to be his goals his fantasies
which is why I believe they're exactly
that fantasies delusions hallucinations
if he were truly the leader of this
rebellion would he be allowed to walk
through the crowd in his clown makeup
well everyone is protesting in one
direction would he just be allowed to
walk in the other direction consider
this all the signs in the crowd are
about capitalism in the working-class
pause the trailers and progress frame by
frame through them and you can see these
protests are for workers rights does
that seem to be the type of message that
Arthur Fleck the Joker would be the
figurehead for or is he just inserting
himself into these protests as some sort
of power fantasy this scene of him
kissing the girl that he's trying to
impress does that sort of confident
behavior look like it's coming from a
man as shy and now
see is our third I don't think so I
think these are all part of his
hallucinations the delusional world
where he lives because of his mental
illness as he himself says in the final
trailer let's face it the comic book
industry is no stranger to misleading
trailers heck Marvel's turned digitally
altering their trailers into something
of a sport giving us a two-eyed Thor and
ragnaroks trailer 2d hulking of Mark
Ruffalo and the end game trailers
amongst dozens of other changes remember
I even made a theory about where the
soulstone was based entirely on
digitally edited shots from infinity war
yeah thanks Marvel not gonna forget
about that one anytime soon but showing
straight-up fantasies from the movie is
a brilliant way to misdirect fans DC has
even used this tactic before showing an
intimidating Superman in Batman V
Superman's trailer that actually just
came from one of Batman's dream
sequences because we know that the Joker
is gonna struggle with mental illness in
this movie there's some good reason to
believe that he's not gonna be entirely
connected to reality I think there's a
very strong possibility that every time
we see Arthur as the Joker in this new
movie it'll only be in his head a
delusion we know that there's a villain
called Joker at some point and that
there is a clown themed rebellion in
Gotham but it's about labor disputes the
trailers want us to believe that Arthur
is the mastermind behind it all which
I'm not so sure about Arthur Fleck just
doesn't seem to be a social engineer
like the Joker the trailers are making
him out to be Arthur is a tragic dreamer
just like Rupert and King of Comedy
before him men whose greatest
achievements exists sadly inside their
own minds or who knows it could be wrong
but based on some early reviews that
came out literally as we were editing
this video one of Joker strengths is
that anyone will be able to argue their
side about what was real and what was
imagined it certainly seems like our
theory may have predicted the punchline
but hey that's just a theory
a film theory
and cuts